[Music]
if you love superhero movies but you
think the big problem is there aren't
enough chicks this movie is still
terrible you're forgetting
something I'm reveng
Vault we have to stop her this is the
start of a new
[Music]
beginning I'm going to give you my a
formal review in just a moment I'm going
to give you a very comprehensive review
it's going to have quadrants and ratings
and numbers and things but first though
I want to tell you what happens in the
movie I want to do that but I can't
because I don't know because I watched
the movie I watched every minute of that
stupid movie and I still have no idea
what happened here's what I know
happened there's a white lady and then
there's a black lady and then there is a
younger more ethnically ambiguous
vaguely Brown kind of girl and so you've
checked all of the racial diversity
there and you got a lot of chicks but I
don't really understand how they relate
to one another the white lady is Captain
Marvel she's the only one whose name I
really remember then the black lady
related to Captain Marvel when she was
little or something but then Captain
Marvel went away and she was angry about
that and then the girl the newcomer girl
her her character name I do remember
it's Kamala I remember it because of the
vice president it's Kamala KH and she's
a big fan of Captain Marvel and this was
when I knew this movie was going to be
terrible because the movie has no
relationship to reality whatsoever
because the very first premise that I've
got to swallow in the movie is that
little girls are just idolizing Captain
Marvel that they're lying on their bed
saying when I grow up I want to be
Captain Marvel which is what the
feminists want little girls to do they
want them to lie on their bed they want
to pretend that little girls want to be
big superhero wrestler Sumo boxers
someday or something but they don't
little girls want to be princesses and
they want to be swept off their feet by
Prince Charming and they want to do what
women have done for all of history and
they're going to have the same desires
as that women have had for all of
history and so the feminist clap trap
that's come about since the 1960s is
just fake and it's fake because it
doesn't explain how women really behave
but it also doesn't even speak to the
desires that women have so from the
beginning I said oh no here we go here
we go then Samuel Al Jackson comes in
and he's running around his sort of
Chaos ship doing something I don't know
he's a guy he's a guy and he's telling
them about a mission or something and
the there's a bad girl she's a girl D
Dar Binks or I don't know whatever the
DAR character is she's going to destroy
the world and so Captain Marvel and the
other lady and the kid have to stop her
but the reason they all have to do it
together is because they've become
entangled they discovered an ancient
artifact and because of this they switch
places all the time and why and how do
they switch places I don't really know
the filmmakers try to explain this
probably two or three or four times and
it never makes any more sense than it
did the previous time and it's really
just a cheap little film making trick
which is whenever the writers have
gotten themselves into a spot where they
can't write themselves out of it they
can just switch the characters out and
completely avoid any of the problems of
actual storytelling so you've got these
characters who are all extraordinarily
one-dimensional with no Stakes
whatsoever there's this minor conflict
between Captain Marvel and the other
lady but they just resolved that by
spoiler alert Captain Marvel says hey
I'm sorry I left and then the other lady
says oh it's okay let's work together
now so that resolves those Stakes for
whatever they were worth and then the
little girl her Stakes are that she
really likes Captain Marvel and she's
really in awe of Captain Marvel she's
Star Struck and then Captain Marvel's
like hey stop being so Star Struck and
she's like okay that's fine and then
they all work together so that was it
they resolved that issue and then I
don't know what the evil person's doing
some lady who has a few villainous
moments but but otherwise you're never
afraid of anything and then there's the
big exciting scene and and nothing
really happens whatsoever the two most
notable aspects of the movie there's a
cat who keeps showing up which I
actually like to me this is the most
truthful aspect of the movie because it
proves that Captain Marvel is just a
witch CU she's got this little cat like
her familiar Spirit that's around with
her like all witches throughout all of
history because women who cast weird
magic spells and would travel through
the air you know on like on broomsticks
uh they were called witches in the past
and so this is a nice nod to that and I
got a kick out of it the other notable
aspect of the movie is there's a song
and dance number they arrive at some
planet and in this planet the way the
people communicate is they do song and
dance so they do that for a little bit
for no reason and then they they work it
out and they fight and they beat the bad
guy the most obvious thing wrong with
the movie is the feminism at the
physical level the notion that these
women can fight men physically they can
we know that cuz men are physically
stronger than women so then they say
well no they can cuz they're super women
but okay what's the superpower the whole
point of superhero movies is they're
supposed to tell you something about
human nature the the superhero power in
the feminist world is just becoming a
man which probably explains why we've
gone in short order from feminist
ideology to a complete eraser of the
distinctions between the Sexes to a
complete abolition of marriage to now
transgender ideology because the
feminists really believe it's a very
anti-woman view that the way that you
can make a woman an ordinary woman super
is just to turn her into a man but that
is not the case and it's actually a
deeply misogynistic view to hold and
it's not compelling at all for the
audience underneath that women and men
don't want to see women fight the bad
guys and Men swept off their feet by
Princess Charming that's just an
inversion of desire there's really no
role for men in this movie and the women
are from whatever Planet Captain Marvel
from you know it's bad cuz I took a
quick little perusal I said am I being
am I being harsh overly harsh on this
and no even the liberal critics admit
this thing is just horrific the one
silver lining is that the young girl is
is pretty good she gives the best
performance it is possible to give with
this horrific script in this dumb
universe that they've created but
otherwise it's it's totally unbearable
even the liberal critics admit it the
problem with superhero movies even if
you like them is when they start to
break their own rules is when they start
to just make up rules on the fly when
the rules can't be explained when the
screenwriters have to try to explain
three and four times why it is that all
the characters are switching places and
no one quite ever gets to it and it's
just shoddily written and there are lame
excuses for flashbacks to the first
movie and who knows maybe Marvel is
building towards some bigger movie here
and this is just a stepping stone but if
it is I shudder to think what that will
be right now go to genus c.com NES
letter y letter T our friends at genus
cell have launched a new product called
genus cell 3 which works fast on your
under eye bags and puffiness genus cell
3 is smoother more luxurious and it uses
advanced technology to deliver complex
vitamins and minerals directly to your
face for instant hydration it is like
Gatorade for your skin this new genus
cell technology keeps your skin looking
young and healthy for years to come the
genus cell fall Classics package also
includes a jawline treatment for a more
firm neck and jawline it also includes
genus cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer
and deep Firming Serum get your skin
ready for the cold and dry weather if
you don't look and feel your absolute
best you will get your money back no
questions asked go to genucell.com nyt
or you can call 800 skin skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package results in 12 hours or less the
immedia effects are included for free by
the way the founder of this company
great Coptic Christian from Egypt who
left there for the American dream so
head on over to genucell.com noes letter
y letter T or call 800 skin SK i n 211
for those who are unfamiliar with it my
my grading scale I still don't quite
understand it myself but Mr Davies and I
thought it up you've got one axis it's
lame to Epic and then you got that's the
y axis I guess right then you got the x
axis and that is lib to Trad and then
you impose on the axis quadrants let's
say you're here right and you go epic
Trad that's like Braveheart that's like
The Passion of the Christ that is
disproportionately M Gibson movies if
you are thinking of a really epic movie
that gets plotts but it's super lib
you'd think of a movie like American
Beauty now if you think of a movie
that's that's extremely lame and super
lib you think of a movie like uh the the
all chick Ghostbusters or now I think
we're going to actually have to replace
that one with a new example and then if
you think of a movie that is traditional
and conservative but not perhaps not as
gloriously made Mr Davies said it not me
he said well an example of one of these
movies would be maybe some of the movies
that I Ben Davies have been in not all
he's been in he's been in great movies
but maybe some would fit into that
quadron and where does the Marvels go
it's a zero it's so lame it's so
powerfully lame it it is as though the
Cartman version of Kathleen Kennedy
wrote this script herself and then
directed it and then edited it put a
kick in it make her gay it's just that
lame it's a complete perfect zero now
this where it gets a little unexpected
maybe on the scale of super lib to Super
Trad it's not a zero it's not it's it
would almost be better if it were super
Li it would almost be better if this
were written by Angela Davis and it were
a bunch of radical communist Amazonian
half lesbian terrorist woman at least
then it there would be something
interesting about it it's not it's
perfectly
pasteurized corporate woke completely
inoffensive other than to Good Taste but
it's it's
inoffensive to any mainstream Center
left political gobbledygook slop so
there's no the nearest thing they have
to something being woke is the diversity
casting they have you know different
shade and every different color and the
white guys are the bad guys and but even
that is so lame at this point there's
nothing edgy about that it's so on the
woke scale on the lib to Trad scale I'd
give it a three maybe a four let's give
it a three and A2 on that scale so the
movie then on a scale of what what is it
0 to 20 I guess I'd give it a three and
1/2 totally bottom of the barrel on
epicness but just like a little only a
little bit on the lib side to quote my
distant cousin Hillary Clinton it's just
a a movie to be thrown in with the
basket of other deplorables and never
heard from again see you next
[Music]
time that was a really important
journalism we just did